More personal.
Hey I'm Jad Abumrad This is more perfect today two stories from reporter
Catherine wells.
The first has some adult content in it so be warned if you listening with kids
you might wanna skip this one. Here's Catherine.
So maybe we can start with the the night that it started. Yeah.
So we didn't start with a start.
Yeah.
So give me the who what when where the best way to describe being on patrol
officer on the street is you have a front row seat to the Greatest Show on
Earth.
September 17th 1998 on the outskirts of Houston there's a deputy sheriff named
Joseph Quinn had been on duty very long at all.
He's driving around and he hears this call go out the radio priority call
somebody is called in and said There's a man gone crazy with a gun in an
apartment.
He happens to be driving right by the apartment complex.
Pretty familiar with the complex. I knew where the building was.
So he's like Hey I got this I'm right here I'm going home.
So I parked and I tried to be as tactical as I could listen and see if I hear
any kind of sound to distinguish.
Walked into the breezeway on high alert senses heightened adrenaline pumping
and out in the middle courtyard.
There was a gentleman standing out there as soon as he saw me.
He started yelling Over here over here I can telling you I was upset he was
crying. He said he's up there he's up there I said Up where.
And he points up to this apartment on the second floor.
I said the man with a gun is up there.
Is that where you're saying that apartment right there. He said Yeah.
So a couple other officers arrive and they get information.
We took our time control your breathing to get that
you know the adrenaline rush and the blood pressure down to where you don't get
tunnel vision.
Went up the stairs for us.
When they get up to the top of the stairs got to the apartment door and their
door was ajar it was open. I listened for a second
game to get in and find that I could detect anything in the apartment.
So we got ready and I pushed the door open all the way open.
I announced our presence the sheriff's department anyone in the apartment come
out where we could see you.
Keep your hands in plain sight.
I did this two or three times very loudly. Still no response.
There is a bedroom in the back of the apartment.
It was a door to a back bedroom that was closed.
And these two officers start walking towards it.
The deputy that was in front of me.
He opened the door pushed it open and as soon as he did he lurched back like he
would startle.
So he goes into the bedroom finger's on the trigger pressure fold if I see a gun
and it's pointed at me. I'm gonna take him out. But then. It's like.
You got to be kidding me. Really.
What was it. What was it. It was. Two guys having sex.
Oh something I'll never forget. I mean it's like
I just I was just flabbergasted.
Okay so here's the story.
The two guys that were in the apartment where John Lawrence and Tyrone Garner
John was an older white guy. He was in his 50s.
And Tyrone was a younger black guy in his thirties.
Come to find out. Basically the gentleman downstairs.
This is the guy who called nine one one was former lover or on again off again
lover one and he was upset that the other that they were engaged in some kind of
activity was OK.
So the guy in the parking lot was the boyfriend of Tehran.
And we don't really know why he called 9 1 1 but the thought is that maybe he
was jealous of whatever was going on in the apartment and he decided he wanted
to get them in trouble.
You know it was a lover's triangle kind of thing.
So you know the cops come in and John and Tyrone have no idea what's going on.
They didn't know that the boyfriend had gone and called 9 1 1 so they're
shocked. And Quinn says they start yelling at him.
Just I mean combative belligerent refusing to comply with anything we hated gays
we were homophobes we were jackbooted Nazi thugs.
So at a certain point Quinn just decides you know if we leave him here and the
way they're acting and they're intoxicated we're going to have further calls
here. Know it's not and if we leave them here we decide to arrest them.
Really what's on what charge. I mean they're just in their house. Right.
So that's the question.
Well I've been a Coleman for 15 years and you know I'm blessed with the ability
to have somewhat of what you would call a photographic memory.
Meaning he knew the penal code really well.
So he starts thinking he starts going through all the possible laws that could
apply to this and he lands on this one.
I know it pretty well twenty one o say statute 21 06.
It says Members of the same sex can engage in sexual conduct.
It's a law banning sodomy deviant sexual intercourse.
We were not even treated like civilized citizens.
This is John Lawrence from an interview he did with Lambda Legal in 2008.
It's one of the few bits of tape that we have of him.
This is all of a sudden we're taking you downtown.
I wasn't allowed to put clothes on. I was handcuffed and dragged downstairs.
Officer Joe Quinn has a different version of that story to the main custody
afforded him the opportunity to get dressed.
They refused so we forced him to put some underwear on.
You know we actually l Elam down to put underwear on them and escort in the
Mallee apartment like that because we I mean it was it was a struggle just to
get them to put underwear on.
You just jumped for saying whatever happened in that room which Catherine will
go into more in a second.
This moment of two guys supposedly having sex and I mean charged with sodomy.
It was like a strike of lightning.
It would begin a process that would profoundly reshape America.
And what's interesting and this is one of the first things that you bump into if
you were an idiot about the law which I am.
And then you try and make a podcast about the law.
I'm trying to do is that there's often this disconnect.
Like laws are these things that sort of float above us all these beautiful
abstractions.
And yet if you want to challenge law you've got to find a person down here in
the mud whose experience perfectly somehow captures what you feel is wrong with
the law. You've got to find a perfect plaintiff.
But how do you find that person. What happens if they're not so perfect.
These two stories you're gonna hear are about a particular tactic that sometimes
called test case litigation that I wasn't too aware of before Kathleen's
reporting.
The second story actually touches on a very current case that was just decided a
few days ago.
The case on affirmative action will meet the guy who brought that case who
critics say is basically destroying some of the most iconic civil rights law
from the 60s.
But first we'll get back to Catherine wells with the story of a case called
Lawrence v. Texas. OK so come on in.
I brought out my Lawrence versus Texas box of stuff.
So I went to Houston and I visited a guy named Mitchell KTM.
He's a lawyer there. And he showed me the arrest papers.
He had the arrest papers for these two guys C.J.
Lawrence criminal officers observed the defendant engaged in deviant sexual
conduct charged with homosexual conduct. It's right there in writing.
Yeah. I mean it's it really is strange to see those words on a piece of paper.
It seems like such an anachronism. But it was not.
That's. And this is dated timber 17th 1998.
Now in 1998 a few other things.
Texas wasn't the only state that had this kind of law on the books at least 13
other states also had an anti sodomy law.
And it's important to note that you know this law wasn't used very much.
People were not arrested for this law because when would police be present in
your home to observe you having sex.
This is Dale Carpenter I teach constitutional law at SMU Law School.
I mean sodomy laws weren't really about stopping any body from having sex.
They were really about ensuring that we could label people criminal.
It was a label that people could point to so that people who disapproved of
homosexuality could say look that defining act.
Of homosexuality a crime.
So if it's a crime and you commit the crime well you're a criminal it's a
criminal statute.
People can say you're a criminal which then gives the state a legal basis to
justify all sorts of housing discrimination employment discrimination military
in every context it had an effect and many people argued that these laws they
also sent a strong cultural message what's being called gay bashing.
But the most recent example here in Houston is better described as a vicious
killing.
And this was at a time when the hate crimes in Houston were surprisingly common.
Paul Batista 27 years old died after being beaten with a nail studded to buy for
the second senseless killing in the Montrose area in less than three months.
It was a lot of blood and was real apparent that he'd been shot. So.
To make a long story short the gay rights movement is very eager to repeal that
sodomy law.
OK so John and Tyrone were arrested on a Thursday night the next day.
It so happened that.
Because of the location of John Lawrence's apartment the case landed in a
justice of the peace court meaning after Quinn made the arrest the report was
sent to that court for processing.
Now this court is mostly deals with traffic it's mostly a traffic court but
there happens to be this clerk in the court who was gay and he couldn't believe
that there that somebody had actually been arrested for homosexual conduct in
their home.
So that night this clerk and his partner go to a bar and they start talking to
the bartender.
I believe it was a Friday night. This is Leanne Lewis. He was the bartender.
When I was doing I was a bartender in 1998.
So these two guys come in and they tell Lane you're not going to believe what
happened.
They said a couple of guys were arrested and charged with sodomy.
And Lane was like yeah yeah yeah yeah.
You just can't believe that such a thing happened it's such an unusual
occurrence. But they were like No no it really happened.
And Lane said Send me the report Monday morning bright and early.
I can hear my fax machine go off and then I pull it off.
Officers observed the defendant engaged in deviant sexual conduct and oral sex.
And then that's when it hit me.
Oh I mean it was so clear night and day to me I immediately knew what I had in
my hand.
Why why does he care so much about this man.
Well so when he wasn't being a bartender Lane was a community organizer
particularly around LGBT issues.
I was president of the Gay and Lesbian Political Caucus.
That's one of the oldest LGBT civil rights groups in the south.
He'd been waiting for this moment. How long had you been looking for a case.
Seven eight years. Seven or eight years.
Cause just to lay it out explicitly what why did you need it.
I needed a test case.
You can't change a law like that if you don't have a case.
People in the Texas legislature had been trying to remove this law from the
books for years.
According to Dale Carpenter but every time someone would introduce a proposal to
repeal the law it would get Snickers and catcalls in the state legislature.
It just wasn't really going anywhere.
So activists had decided the only way to get this done is to bypass the
legislature and go straight to the courts.
So I needed a case I had to have someone guilty.
So Lane starts trying to track them down at this point the two guys had been
released from jail and he eventually gets drawn on the phone conversation
basically went like this.
Hi my name is Lane Lewis. I'm a gay activist here in town. You don't know me.
That's not important but I understand you've been arrested.
I'm begging you not to plead out meaning don't just say you did it and pay the
fine.
I knew I couldn't have em plead out because then there'd be nothing Lane could
do.
I said I will find you lawyers. I will raise the money.
I will pay for everything.
Just don't do anything until you and I have an opportunity to meet.
A few weeks later they all meet at Mitchell Cortines office and it immediately
becomes clear that these guys are sort of an odd couple.
JOHN LAWRENCE At that time was about I think it was 55 years old tall white kind
of a big guy.
He worked as a lab technician for a hospital.
Tyrone Gardner was a young skinny black guy 24 years younger than John.
No steady job.
He bounced around between friends apartments just kind of went from place to
place and job to job.
No idea what their connection was. They weren't lovers both heavy drinkers
very heavy.
Both had criminal records.
Yes Tyrone had been convicted of assault and drug possession.
And John had been convicted in the 60s of murder by automobile.
They were not the perfect plane but they were not the poster boys these were not
pretty tweaks and they weren't political. No not at all not at all.
In fact when Lane told John Lawrence I'm a gay activist here in town.
John Lawrence didn't even know what that was.
I don't know what a gay activist is.
Basically neither of them had any interests like no interest in being a public
figure. So I gave him the whole Ask not.
What your country can do for you ask not what you can do for your country
speech.
I mean literally I reminded them of who Harry Hay was.
I just simply thought well now it's time for me to organize my people.
Well Harry Hay was arguably the founder of the original LGBT movement.
You listeners may not remember but at one time it was illegal for certain number
of gay males and the LGBT community to get together and one location was illegal
can do it.
I dreamt even then of the idea that there would be networks of sanctuaries or
places where we could come and out of which we would be able to move and
organize and change things across the country.
So I told him a little bit about that history and.
How far we'd come and how far we had to go.
And that they had an opportunity to change their.
So I told him I said. I'll be able to protect you.
For maybe the first year or two but there's going to come a time where I will no
longer be about you. It'll be about something much much bigger.
So. They agreed
Tyrone's attitude was OK. You know what do you need me to do.
John was much more indignant.
I was pissed.
They picked the wrong person to pull this loan.
There was a ridiculous law but Texas loves to keep some antiquated things
around.
He was mad. He was angry.
And here's where the story gets complicated because at one point according to
Lane Lewis they were having this conversation and John was ranting you know
about how he'd been treated and he said you know what the worst part is we won't
even in fact you know we want to get up.
He said that they were not having sex. Wait what.
That they were not having sex that they were sitting in their underwear on the
couch watching the late night news.
They say they were sitting there doing nothing.
And the cops just burst in and started pushing them around and that they were
never even having sex.
But isn't this whole case about them having sex. Yeah.
So you're saying the thing that this case is supposed to be about may not be
true right.
Well so I interviewed three of the four police officers Dale Carpenter says when
he talked to the police officers he did find that their stories were sort of all
over the place.
One guy said it was anal sex he saw one guy later said he thought it might have
been oral.
The other two officers said they never saw anything.
So Dale says he believes John's story there probably was actually no sex.
He thinks what might have happened is that the cops walked in and saw some gay
art on the wall and some gay magazines lying around.
I have a feeling that really set off the officers and they said well we know
they're homosexuals they probably engaged in homosexual conduct at some point
and that's illegal in Texas.
No no I. There was no no no doubt about it.
I mean I have no no reason to lie.
QUINN To this day still insists that he walked in on them and copulate.
He says he saw what he saw and he just did his job.
If you want to be homosexual and that's where you want leave your lifestyle
that's fine. I don't agree with your lifestyle but that's my opinion.
That's what it is. It's an opinion.
So there's no way to know what actually happened obviously but in a way it
doesn't matter because when John said that to Lane that they weren't even having
sex as a John Don't ever say that again.
Don't ever say that to anybody. Again.
Because we couldn't have people know that we couldn't have people find that out.
We can go forward to this. Yep.
We were scared that the case would get screwed up at that point and potentially
the D.A. dropping the charges.
So basically you had to preserve if if Joe Quinn was lying on that police report
you had to preserve the lie correct.
Correct. Dumb question.
You can just do that you can just preserve a lie to keep a case going.
You do that.
Well keep in mind and it wasn't our job to prove or disprove the lie.
You know Elaine the thing that mattered was not what did or didn't happen that
night. The thing that mattered was what the arrest report said.
But if what the arrest report said potentially didn't happen should that matter.
Well no. No one.
Our legal system is not designed to bring out the truth.
This is a misconception. It does not bring out the truth.
That's Dale Carpenter again it is people who play their roles in pursuing
whatever they think their best interests are. And that's exactly what happened.
So for the first few years my job was to keep the boys out of the out of the
news. And why was that.
Well they had a tendency to drink and get rowdy and fight and they like to go to
seedy hotels and rent rooms and get really really high drunk whatever.
And inevitably they would start fighting with each other.
And so what I did what I would do is I would.
I knew the different places they stayed.
He says he would go to these seedy hotels and talk to the clerks give him a
business card tell him if these boys come and check in they cause problems.
Call me first ban on more than one occasion that happened I'd get a call at 2
o'clock in the morning.
Your guys are here they're causing trouble I'm gonna have to call the cops.
I would jump out of bed put on my clothes because we couldn't have them.
You know they're already on the front page of The Houston Chronicle.
We could not have our defendants doing a perp walk for drugs and alcohol.
So I would drive down there and I would figure out which one was causing the
most problems. Put them in my car and I would drive them somewhere else.
I would separate them out.
That happened more than once more than once.
Celine said he had this fear that John and Tyrone Woods would start talking to
the media and let something slip about their version of the story.
So he gave them these little cards kept it in their wallet and small little
sentences basically said thank you for contacting me.
Please refer to Lane Lewis and had my phone number and my email and I said so
anytime the media contacts you don't think about what you say right.
That's where you get screwed up.
When you start thinking about what you want to say to the media pull this out of
your wallet read it.
And hang up.
Even so there were these close calls as the case wound its way through the court
system.
Mitchell KTM told me about this one time there was this press conference and we
came outside to the normal media group that was out there wanting quotes and
talk to us and they didn't want to hear from the lawyers they wanted to hear
from the clients.
So it was like All right just this once Tyrone got up to the mike and I think a
reporter asked him you know how do you feel about this.
And he said we didn't do anything wrong.
He just kind of yelled that out in a angry way we didn't do anything wrong.
Mitchell pulled him back and was like Oh that's enough that's enough.
Next day we didn't do anything wrong.
That was the quote on the headlines of the morning's paper the next day.
And certainly I knew what he meant. That they weren't having sex but you know.
Could also be interpreted as homosexual conduct is nothing wrong.
He says luckily that's how people took it.
It's very nerve wracking because this went on for years this was years.
Yeah couple of years. Here's kind of how it went down.
They started at this justice of the peace court.
They were sentenced to a fine of one hundred and twenty five bucks.
They appealed and the case gets kicked up one level to the Harris County
criminal court. They're fined again. They appeal it again.
Then it went to another level to the 14th Court of Appeals.
And one more level ultimately the Texas Criminal Court of Appeals which is the
highest court in Texas for Criminal Appeals refused even to hear the case.
So the only next step is the Supreme Court
will hear argument next to no.
0 2 1 0 2.
John get as Lawrence and Tyron Garner versus Texas March 26 2003 almost five
years after the arrest the case lands at the Supreme Court.
And by the time it gets up there Mr. Smith.
Mr. Chief Justice and may it please the court.
The story is not dwelled upon at all.
They didn't say these guys weren't in a relationship.
They didn't say if these guys were having sex.
One of them was cheating on his partner.
Seems like they might have not been having sex anyway.
They didn't say any of those things they said there are gay families that family
relationships are established that there are hundreds of thousands of people
that this is about families and relationships.
How people in loving relationships have the right to express themselves in
whatever they want it's none of the state's business.
The opportunity to engage in sexual expression as they will in the privacy of
their home homes performs much the same function that it does in the marital
context.
You know basically people in relationships have the right to have sex with each
other regardless of their gender.
You should protect it for everyone that this isn't a fundamental matter of
American values.
So now it's like watching something float up from the sort of mucky like realm
of human real life real life and then it just gets kind of prettier as it floats
upwards.
Yeah it was such a pretty story that people were suspicious of it like people
were asking how did this arrest even happen.
This was a setup. You all set this up. That was their big battle cry.
So Mitchell Curtin says he heard this over and over again.
It wasn't a setup but I always wanted to say so so what if it was.
Does that make it any less of a case.
Who cares unless the court has further questions. Thank you very much.
Thank you Mr. Smith. The case is submitted to.
The honorable court is now adjourned until Monday next 10:00.
Three months later the opinion of the court. No.
0 2 1 0 2 Lawrence against Texas will be announced by Justice Kennedy.
Justice Kennedy begins reading a summary of his opinion.
The question before the court is the validity of a Texas statute making it a
crime for two persons of the same sex to engage in certain intimate sexual
conduct. And everybody's waiting for the outcome.
In Houston Texas police officers.
So for context it wasn't totally clear how this case was gonna come out because
17 years earlier there'd been a case called Bowers against Hardwick Bowers vs.
Hardwick and then they had ruled that sodomy laws were fine and I would suggest
to the court that there is no constitutional right to conclude.
That there should be a fundamental right to engage in homosexual sodomy.
And the Supreme Court almost never overrules things that are that recent Bowers
vs. Hardwick had some factual similarities to this case.
So Justice Kennedy starts talking about all the similarities between the cases
these officers were dispatched to a private residence.
The tension starts building officers observed Lawrence and another man Tyron
Garner engaging in a sexual way and then finally he got to the moment where he
said Morris was not correct when it was decided.
And is not correct today.
And at the point Justice Kennedy said that there were people sobbing in the
Supreme Court Barrios vs. Hardwick should be and now is overruled.
At rallies across the nation gay rights advocates celebrated their legal
victory. A ruling so broad it surprised even many of them.
The court ruled in favor of two Texas men who challenged the state law that made
homosexual sex a crime.
The ruling overturns a Texas law that allowed police to arrest gays for having
sex.
Twelve other states have similar laws including that morning John Lawrence was
at home in his apartment in Houston watching them.
I am laying in bed trying to go back get my 40 works and all of a sudden as this
has ruled the law unconstitutional.
I came out of bed quite happy
obviously not everybody was happy about it.
Let me be clear that I have nothing against homosexuals or any other group
promoting their agenda through law school through normal democratic means
Justice Scalia said.
Basically if you want this to happen that's fine but you're going about it the
wrong way. The court is not the place where this decision should be made.
You need to go talk to your fellow citizens and convince them that this law
needs to change.
Coming to us and asking us to bypass what your fellow citizens seem to want.
That is not how democracy should work persuading one's fellow citizens is one
thing and imposing one's views in absence of Democratic majority will is
something else.
He sees this as a small minority imposing their views on everybody else and then
he said he was worried about something else.
Today's opinion dismantles the structure of constitutional law that has
permitted a distinction to be made between heterosexual and homosexual.
That this decision would open the floodgates and that it would only be a matter
of time before the court was being asked to decide on gay marriage like the
relevant principal. And he was right.
When Kennedy read the marriage decision in 2015 in Lawrence vs.
Texas he talked about Lawrence.
The court held that private intimacy of same sex couples cannot be declared a
crime. Yet it does not follow that freedom stops there. Outlaw.
To outcast may be a step forward.
But it does not achieve the full promise of liberty.
So what happened to Garner in Lawrence.
Well John Lawrence and Tyron Garner didn't live to see this.
Tyrone died in 2006 from meningitis.
No job had no money.
He was 39 and his family was very poor and they didn't have the money to bury
him. They didn't even have the money to reclaim his body from the county morgue.
As for John Lawrence he died in 2011 at 68 from heart problems.
We didn't even find out about it until a month after he was dead.
This hero of the gay rights movement was unknown and UN warned that his passing
what does that say about sort of the.
Practice of bringing things to the Supreme Court.
That the two people whose story this case revolves around could sort of fade
into the background afterwards.
Well one is tempted I think to be very cynical in some ways because it means
that these people were useful as long as they were useful.
And after that they could be forgotten.
I have to say I actually had their reaction a little bit.
I mean this is a story of social progress but there's something a little funny
at the center of it for me.
And as we were playing this for our legal editor Elena Stahl And I think that we
talked about spin in a lot of ways.
Our legal system devolves into an end justifies the means kind of justice.
We say we care we care about the process so much and look at the processes it is
extremely important.
Ellie isn't this just weird to you like this is a dumb law like a dumb dumb dumb
dumb law.
Why not just shouldn't there be an avenue to say this is a dumb law was taken
away why did you have to find some people who didn't have sex they say pretend
that they have sex then march them up all the way through the court system and
then forget about them.
I mean it just seems weird to me it seems like a empty theater.
Why do we have to do it that way.
Because if you want to put a ballot initiative up in 2003 in Texas saying is gay
sex OK it would fail it would fail in 2003 in Texas it would probably fail in
2016 in Texas. It will probably fail in 2032.
In Texas that's why that's why the majority isn't always right.
So you you.
Take you basically take the Democratic vote and this is this is a again this
goes back right to the founding of our country like When are you gonna let
popular will run wild and when are you going to constrain it not just restrain
and constrain it. When are you going to stop it.
And Lawrence v.
Texas is as an example of a we're just going to stop it.
And it was the right call.
So after this Supreme Court decision did Texas immediately go and repeal the
law.
No actually the law is still on the books in Texas.
No the Texas legislature like other legislatures around the country refuses to
repeal the law.
It stays there a a remnant of a kind of a dark almost forgotten past.
Keep in mind they can't enforce the law now that it's unconstitutional but they
refused to take it off.
Coming up a very deep dive into the guy behind one of the most controversial
cases this term. A case that just got decided late last week.
This is more perfect
Chief Justices of the Supreme Court of the United States.
Oh yay yay yay persons having business before the honorable the supreme court of
the United States are admonished to draw near their own
God save the United States in this horrible cartoon.
Hi my name's Peter Fink and I'm calling for it so no refugee camp in the area.
Greece Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred P.
Sloan Foundation enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the
modern world. More information about sloan.
W w w dot Sloan dot org.
Hi I'm Bassem Youssef. I have a new show Remade in America presented by café.
I'm exploring what it's like to be an outsider in this country.
I'm talking to people from all walks of life people like me who came here from
other countries and people who were born here but never felt like they totally
fit in like our recent guest.
Cameron Esposito when I realized I was gay I was at a college where you could be
kicked out of school for being gay.
Join us as we talk about America from a totally different perspective.
This is more perfect.
I'm Jad Abumrad if Supreme Court cases can sometimes feel like plays where the
activist and lawyers are sort of like the directors pulling the strings and the
people in the center of the case the plaintiffs are just like these imperfect
actors who have been cast in the script sort of been written for them.
Well that dynamic was definitely in effect this term.
In fact just last week.
We have had a decision just handed down in what was billed as the landmark
affirmative action case of this term.
Josh this is a decision that will impact college admissions nationwide.
The case Fisher versus University of Texas centered around the following
question should universities be able to use racial preferences in college
admissions.
Now the University of Texas has this policy where the top 10 percent of every
high school class automatically get in.
But for everybody else they will consider factors like race.
The question was Is that OK.
A couple days ago the court decided barely yes it is OK.
The Supreme Court has upheld the affirmative action program at the University of
Texas affirmative action and higher education is constitutional.
Now the case was brought by a young white woman named Abigail Fisher.
Abigail Fisher Abigail Fisher believed her race may have hurt her chances to
attend the University of Texas.
There were people in my class with lower grades who weren't in all the
activities I was in who were being accepted into the team.
And the only other difference between us is the color of our skin.
She was arguing that affirmative action discriminates against her as a white
person.
Now what you saw in the wake of that decision and even before especially online
was just a torrent of hate.
Directed squarely at her.
So I'm trying to hold my tongue but I'm about to tell Abby to have a seat.
OK I can't get into a good college.
Black people have a better pitch if you don't take your class somewhere.
Maybe if her grades didn't suck you dumb ass maybe you would have gotten into a
good college with the bad grades.
Really happy you and your racist lawyer guy sat down.
It's all been pointed right at Abby Fisher which you could argue honestly isn't
fair because this case may have very little to do with Abby Fisher.
I mean if you look at the press conference I don't believe that student should
be treated differently based on their race.
Abby Fisher is the one at the podium but behind her far in the background and
you'll see the sky he's there in every single press conference sort of back in
the air at the edge of the frame.
Not too many people know about him His name is Edward Bloom and he's the one who
actually brought the case when it comes to this case and so many others.
He is the architect.
He's brought dozens of lawsuits not just this one.
And he seems to be a maestro of getting cases to the Supreme Court that
challenged civil rights law
critics sort of paint him as this like one man wrecking crew for civil rights
like he's almost single handedly rolling back decades of civil rights law.
And when it comes to affirmative action he says he's not done just to make a
long story short we wanted to meet him figure out how he does.
Yeah. So I went to Tallahassee. Reporter Katherine Wells takes from here.
That's where he lives or he winters in Tallahassee.
Golden retriever.
You walk in.
What initially struck you his golden retriever is what initially struck me
literally physically. Nice meeting here.
Of course.
And I don't know what I was expecting but when you hear about these cases you
know they're I mean critics are really people are mad about these cases is
deeply disturbed.
Truly outrageous so betrayal of the American people.
So I go to meet him and your flight from Austin to Dallas to Tallahassee
uneventful and on time and good. Do you think. Good.
He's like a totally nice guy.
He's a regular guy. Was he look like like a dad.
There is something in me that just loves tradition and custom.
He loves listening to the Great American Songbook.
Life is a beautiful thing. Frank Sinatra as long as I.
And. Ella Fitzgerald.
I love art and museums.
Independent films golf. What's his what's his story.
What's his backstory. Well he's 64.
I was born in a small town in Michigan.
My dad owned a shoe store there. My mom worked with him in the shoe store.
What had been your kind of political leanings up to this point.
Well I'm the first Republican my mother ever met him to use the word typical but
it really was a typical liberal Jewish household.
My mother and father were Franklin Roosevelt Harry Truman Democrats.
Always voted Democrat.
Then he said he was that way too all the way through college the University of
Texas grad school State University of New York where I spent a year studying of
all things.
African literature but he says somewhere along the way his political leanings
sort of started to shift. I spent a summer in Israel
living on a kibbutz and he says he came out of that experience a little less
liberal than he was before.
And you got married and then in the early 80s he is living in Houston working as
a stockbroker. And we met.
Aren't our neighbors.
This particular couple they were New Yorkers who had moved to Houston both grew
up as liberals and the guy he sort of opened my eyes to the world of the neo
cons.
The guy introduced him to these magazines Weekly Standard National Review
Commentary magazines like conservative magazines.
And this was around the time that the neocon movement was really hitting its
stride. You had all these New York liberals defecting is what he says.
Thousands of individuals who grew up in the 1960s that started to question.
The wisdom of these liberal policies.
And he says slowly slowly over time very gradually he became one of those
people.
In any case Fast forward a little bit.
He's living in Houston kind of a garden variety existence and something happens
that sends him on this entirely new path.
Basically he and his wife moved to a new neighborhood.
They moved from the suburbs into the downtown area more urban.
And in 1990 when we went to vote for the first time in our new neighborhood I
realized that the Republican Party had not fielded a candidate to oppose the
Democrat incumbent running for Congress.
This is a district that has almost 600000 people and you don't have a choice.
You've only got one person running. Blum decided to run himself.
I lost I don't. That was no great surprise to anyone.
He actually lost by 32 points.
But along the way it's something really unusual happened during that campaign.
He and his wife lark you know they decided they were going to go meet voters in
their district.
They got a giant printout of all of the addresses in the 18th congressional
district.
What was then called a walking list and they just started going door to door
meeting people handing out literature and they'd walk down say Oak Street.
I would take the even side of Oak Street and my wife would take the odd numbered
side of Oak Street and we would start to walk.
And he says very quickly they realized that the district's shape.
Was funny.
Some houses on one side of the street would be in the district and then the
houses on the other side wouldn't.
And sometimes the district would snake down a highway catch an apartment complex
come back.
It just didn't make sense. This is like Bloom wife of Edward Bloom.
It was peculiar because we had maps that we had to follow and it was very odd
the way some streets were in the districts and some weren't.
Took a while for it all to really sink in as to how this could happen.
After I guess about a week of this we realized that neighbors had been separated
almost house by house because of their race.
He comes to believe that the reason this was done was for the explicit purpose
to create a majority African-American district.
This isn't untrue. This
is from a clear and simple wrong part of the reason this was done was the Voting
Rights Act of 1965.
Millions of Americans are denied the right to vote because of their color.
This act was a giant step forward in civil rights.
You know one of the primary things that did is eliminate barriers to voting like
poll taxes and literacy tests all these strategies that had been used to keep
minorities from voting.
And then this other thing it did sort of in a roundabout way through a series of
interpretations is it encouraged the creation of districts where the majority of
voters were minorities.
And that's because you know one of the strategies that had been used previously
to sort of dilute the minority vote was to take minority communities.
And they called it cracking.
They sort of split them apart into many different districts so that they were
never in the majority enough to elect a representative. Right.
So the Voting Rights Act tried to correct that the 18th Congressional District
was one of these majority minority districts.
The district was drawn by the Texas legislature to have a slight
African-American majority. I think about 51 percent African-American.
But this was the problem.
According to Bloomberg the way they got to that African-American majority was by
creating this district that zigzagged all over the city and cut through
neighborhoods.
I could not understand people lived close together.
They send their kids to the neighborhood schools.
They shopped in the neighborhood shopping centers.
They were worried about neighborhood issues.
To break these neighborhoods apart by race seemed so wrong to me.
In his mind this law was actually not limiting discrimination but actually
perpetuating. Well yeah.
And I don't know what the average person upon realizing this would have done.
But I decided to file a lawsuit.
He decided to sue the state of Texas called a few friends who lived in the 18th
district and a few other districts in Texas.
An African-American Hispanic Indonesia kept looking and looking and looking
until I found a lawyer that I could afford seven thousand dollars a month.
We filed a lawsuit challenging the constitutionality of Texas is redistricting
plan.
The basic charge was yes the Voting Rights Act was good in its day but now it
was being used as this excuse to segregate people into racially polarized
districts.
It worked its way through the lower courts and to my shock and surprise in 1995
We'll hear argument now on number 94 identify George W. Bush vs.
Al Jazeera.
The Supreme Court took it up and you went to oral argument. Yeah we all did.
Mr. Chief Justice and may it please the court.
So there we all are.
Our opponents stepped to the lectern and that issue this direct appeal is the
constitutionality of three congressional districts.
They make their arguments at the court below erroneously ruled a racially
gerrymandered Texas basically said y'all we have to put people together by race.
The Texas Legislature has the obligation to satisfy federal requirements and the
Voting Rights Act is a federal requirement like remember the Voting Rights Act.
We're trying to make sure that there are enough minorities in this district so
that they have a chance to elect a representative then or advocate Mr. Tribe
we'll hear from you made his arguments you get to the point that that was just
being made. Bloom's lawyer basically said but look at the map.
The map is bizarre.
And the only reason it could have gotten this way is because you're only
thinking about race. Only race. Think about it.
That seems messed up isn't that messed up.
It doesn't matter what your ultimate goal is.
You cannot use certain forbidden to race is forbidden by the 14th Amendment to
be used as a tool. In his example the people St.
Mary's and you know it's a very tense situation.
If I'm not asking about in some way do you know any other situation in the law
in which we allow race to be used as a surrogate for him to be unconstitutional
but to use it as a more not racism. How is this done.
I thought that's how you should know about me as you can see by I don't really
think so. That would require me. You did say that didn't.
Let me just say that I didn't let me find say that I say that I'm not.
So in the end when the Supreme Court.
Gives out this very
hair splitting decision that I think gets at this deeper question that in our
society and in our discourse we just haven't figured out how to talk about
anyway.
And it basically said this you know look if you're defining race just as the
color of someone's skin.
The government cannot use that in any way and that's against the constitution.
On the other hand if you take this wider view and you look at race in the
context of history social context then how can the government address
discrimination without taking race into account.
They have to so it's this difficult balance.
You can't look at race but you have to look at race and gender.
The Supreme Court says to Texas look all you're doing in this case is sorting
people based on how they're labeled on a census.
You're not looking at that wider context you're not looking at.
If these communities live next to each other if they share common interests
you're just sorting them based on race alone. And that's not good enough.
You can't do that when the opinion came down.
The Supreme Court ruled in our favor 5 to 4.
That was quite a day.
The day that we won that lawsuit I was.
Got the world on a string. Looked for ever.
After that. Edward Blum decided that this would be a thing.
It became a passion.
He would use the courts to try to strike down every race based policy he could.
The legal team was taken on the road.
I recruited plaintiffs in New York Virginia South Carolina to challenge
congressional district plans and we won in each of those states.
He helped sue school districts in Florida and Texas to end the use of racial
quotas in K through 12 magnet schools.
He went after affirmative action in Houston city contracting.
Today Houston could become the first city to kill affirmative action.
That one was actually a ballot initiative and it failed.
But I've been the architect of over two dozen lawsuits six of which six made it
to the Supreme Court including.
In 2013 in a 5 to 4 vote 5 to 4 very divided court.
The Supreme Court today struck down a key part of the Voting Rights Act of 1965.
Supreme Court today struck down a very important part of the Voting Rights Act.
That key 1965 landmark law is considered one of the most important pieces of
civil rights legislation ever passed.
Shelby County vs. Holder. This decision gutted the Voting Rights Act.
Specifically there was this part of it that said states and counties with a
history of discrimination have to check with the federal government first before
they go about changing their voting laws.
Basically the federal government was saying look you've been up to all this
stuff where now we're watching you.
The Supreme Court said you know times have changed.
That list was made a long time ago and it's outdated.
This decision restores an important constitutional order to our system of
government.
This was Blum's biggest victory.
When Shelby County came down I burst into tears.
I think a lot of people burst into tears when that came down. You know it.
Yeah I know I understand it.
It is deeply disturbing.
I am deeply disappointed deeply disappointed with the court's decision in this
matter. This decision is a betrayal of the American people. This is a game.
Changer during the civil rights movement.
People died for the precious right to vote.
This is Congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee of Houston Texas.
I would like to have the Supreme Court justices go back in time.
Go back in time and march with those who marched.
After Bloody Sunday from Selma to Montgomery.
Ed Blum has a right to his opinion.
It doesn't mean that it has to be the opinion of the United States.
I understand that people were you know gravely upset.
I also know that there were people who were gravely relieved and gravely
gratified.
Yeah but I think what gets a lot of people is that you look at these civil
rights videos you see tens of thousands 40000 people in the streets marching and
you hold that and if you make a split screen in your mind you hold that.
Thousands tens of thousands people on one side on the other side you.
One guy. It does make you ask basic questions about democracy.
That's a false paradigm.
It's that maybe your split screen.
But that's really not the reality of all of this.
Look in 1964 1965 America was held hostage by the legacies of slavery and the
chokehold of Jim Crow.
Fast forward to 2006 the reauthorization of the Voting Rights Act the chokehold
had gone away.
African-Americans in the Deep South registered to vote in numbers that often
exceeded whites participated in elections in numbers that exceeded whites in
terms of electoral opportunities.
We have come 180 degrees from 1968.
We turned those degrees because of the law which you've helped overturn and we
don't know to what degree that is the psychology of America changing or the fact
that we had a law that kept people in line and now that law is gone and now we
see voter I.D.
laws coming back into play which I think any sane person would admit is it is it
is it is an attempt a blatant attempt to disenfranchise people.
So it feels a little bit strange to I mean I completely agree with you.
Things have gotten better.
The same time I think well that was because of the law that's now gone.
Look laws change laws evolve and and at some point they need to come to an end.
OK.
So just to jump back in play something we haven't actually talked about yet is
our original question how how does this actually happen. How does it work.
How is one person
able to be so effective to do this work.
You need a computer a printer a cell phone.
That's really about it.
Where. Who pays for the lawyer fees and who do you go to.
Well there are individuals that know of my work and there are foundations okay.
So he's a five a one see three.
Like the NAACP and Lambda Legal that funded the Lawrence versus Texas case.
And if you're a five a one see three public charity as he is you don't have to
reveal your donors to the public.
We do know a couple of his donors though and they're wealthy very conservative
foundations.
So in the end what he does is just sort of a more maybe a more strategic or
sophisticated version of what Lane Lewis did in the first story.
Like in this case that he just lost last week he knew he wanted to challenge
affirmative action. So the first thing he did was sort of do a casting call.
He set out to find the perfect white student.
He set up a web called you teen not fair dawg.
He made a recruiting video.
It's time for you to stop using race as a factor in the admissions policy pretty
budget.
It's just him looking at the camera in front of a poster that says you teen out
fair.
I encourage all high school students who have been rejected from duty to visit
at your teen not fair dot org.
Tell us your story and then he started talking to the people who responded.
I think I ended up with about one hundred seventy five responses of those about
a hundred were viable with a seventy five you threw out just like oh funky just
outrageous. Well I just didn't think they would be sympathetic.
So we whittled the hundred down to seven that he thought would be sympathetic of
those seven.
There were one or two that you know did not really want to go forward like I
don't want the attention.
They were fearful of you know the backlash anyway to make a long story short.
He ended up finding Abby Fisher because a friend of his called and said Hey my
daughter just got rejected from UTI. I heard you were looking.
I think I'm a very like very like introverted person so I feel like sometimes
there's a lot of pressure but I think in the end it's totally worth it.
And to be able to have a voice in this and to know that my voice is making a
difference is really rewarding.
She seemed like the perfect plaintiff strawberry blonde hair She's petite she's
kind of shy in front of the camera in a good way.
But last week they lost.
So we talked to him before all this happened.
So we weren't able to get a reaction from him but he did tell an Austin
newspaper that the night after the decision came down.
He had three glasses of wine.
He took an Ambien and he thought about these particular lyrics in a Billy Joel
song. A lot of folks. Told me how.
The songs called keeping the faith. I'm a long distance runner.
If there's something just emblematic about my personality I run long distances.
He says he's definitely not done.
He's actually already has two more cases against affirmative action in the
works.
I have retained counsel to litigate Harvard's admissions policies and University
of North Carolina's admissions policies.
I am sorry it just doesn't strike anyone.
I mean forget the politics whether you're on on Bloom's side or not this just
the tactic doesn't strike anyone as like fishy.
I resist giving Ed Bloom that much credit.
That's Ellie Mr. elegant legal editor I would say that fundamentally he's just
implementing a strategy that was perfected by the people he now ironically seeks
to disenfranchise. This is a civil rights movement one to one.
He's got laws that he doesn't like that he knows he can't overturn through an
election. Remember this Blum's a failed congressional candidate.
He had that lust for for political power.
He couldn't get it through the electoral system but he found this other way to
do it. This is exactly what the civil rights movement did OK.
So to me this is one of the most fascinating things about this story.
If we go back to you remember this case there's a famous case called Plessy
versus Ferguson. Sort of no not really Plessy v.
Ferguson I think is a good example.
This is Susan Carl law professor at American University Washington College of
Law. OK. Plessy versus Ferguson 1892.
So that was a case where the state of Louisiana had adopted a new separate cars
law which said that people of color and white people could not ride in the same
train cars. And if you've heard the story this is how it goes.
Somebody named Homer Plessy a black man sits down in a white car.
He is rested and he decides to sue.
And his case goes all the way to the Supreme Court. Now.
The thing about that case is that it was a total setup.
You mean so if we go back.
When Louisiana passed that law requiring separate cars early civil rights groups
were obviously horrified by this. But.
The railroad companies were actually mad about this too because they thought it
would be much more expensive to run the trains if they had to have add
additional trains so they'd have white cards and cars of color.
And so civil rights activists and the railroad companies they recruited somebody
named Homer Plessy who was seven eighths white one eighth African-American.
And they sent him to go sit in a white car on a train.
He got into a first class white people's car.
And they sent somebody to go arrest him like they got a off duty police officer
or something. Well they actually hired a detective.
You could do that at the time that you could hire a private detective to make an
arrest. And so they they hired that person too. So.
Plessy gets under the train the conductor comes by and Plessy is like just
thought I should let you know I'm actually in a black.
And the conductor says Well in that case you're going to need to be on the other
car in this train. Homer Plessy says I'm good actually.
I'm gonna be staying right here. And the conductor says No really.
You have to move.
And Homer Plessy says no really not gonna and things get heated and eventually
this detective that they've hired comes in and arrest them.
And they brought a lawsuit.
That's amazing the whole thing is cooked starting with the arrest to challenge
the separate cars law and they were able to get it up to the U.S. Supreme Court
and they were hoping that they would be able to establish that the idea of
separating the races was unconstitutional.
But unfortunately they miss calculated and the court ruled that the law was
constitutional.
And what they got instead was separate but equal totally backfired.
But.
It was this early example of this other way.
You know if you can find a plaintiff or create a plaintiff you might be able to
bypass the legislature and go to the Supreme Court instead.
The NAACP later picked up on this but they were the true geniuses they perfected
it and they perfected it under circumstances where victories were highly
unlikely.
For example in the early nineteen hundreds.
They do things like send a black guy and a white guy all over New York City to
segregated theaters.
And see if one of them was prevented from being seated.
And if they were they would sue those theaters and when victory is that way then
there was this other law in Louisville Kentucky that said nobody could buy a
house or live on a block in which white people lived if they were
African-American.
So they recruited a white guy to sell a house to a black guy and then they had
the black guy refused to take the house so the white guy could say you said you
would buy the house but now you're reneging on it.
They African-Americans said I'm not buying the house because I can't live there.
White guy sues the black guy. Again it was a manufactured case.
That was one of the MWC piece first victories and that's the case where Justice
Holmes said in a dissent that he ended up not publishing. Hey wait a minute.
This isn't even a real case.
At the time.
Anything that involved manufacturing a case or fomenting litigation.
All of those things were legal. So not just unethical but actually illegal.
Yes criminally illegal.
It was seen as something like how we see ambulance chasing today.
The lawyers for the end WTOP were very aware of these statutes and this came to
a head in the 1950s the MWC P wanted to get the court to end segregated schools.
Basically they wanted to overturn Plessy vs.
Ferguson and the way they were doing this.
They you know they needed the plaintiffs.
So the way they were looking for plaintiffs is going to meetings with parents
and sort of quietly you know suddenly trying to ask parents if they wanted to be
the face of these cases.
Now Virginia knew that they were doing this and they tightened up these
regulations that said you know you can't drum up litigation to try to stop them
from doing this.
So the NAACP sued and they took this issue all the way to the Supreme Court.
That litigation is essential because no matter how illegal it is public
officials are free and interfering in that case the Supreme Court said actually
manufacturing litigation is is a form of political expression really.
And it is totally ok like free speech basically.
Yeah like it's a way of expressing your political viewpoint and test case
litigation exploded after this and in the 60s and 70s.
A lot of other movements the women's movement poor people's movement saw the
success the civil rights movement was having with these strategies that they
adopted them as well.
And now I guess that includes Ed Blum Yeah the founding principles of the civil
rights movement have been embraced by the vast majority of Americans in this
country and those founding principles those founding principles guide these
lawsuits that basic fundamental guiding principle of the civil rights movement
and how it needs to be applied today.
I am that's I can't say what I think of that on family on Family Radio
that that is that is not. That is not accurate.
Absolutely is not carrying the standard forward for civil rights in America.
That is not what he's doing.
But Ali says he is actually doing something that's deeply important to our
political system.
When you look at the current election cycle I see a lot of people who who agree
with Ed Blum they agreed with him in a way that shouldn't be expressed in the
polls. They're out there. This is one way for that.
I mean I mean and that happens I think again that's another callback to the
civil rights movement when you have a minority population who believes in
something they just get trampled in popular elections. OK.
But do they still have a voice. Should they still have a voice.
Should they still have a way to enact change on their behalf over the will of
the majority.
Again that seems to me textbook what courts are supposed to be able to do to
look out for the rights of the minorities political minorities more than kind of
ethnic or racial religious and see that they are not being trampled by majority
driven attorney.
Ed Blum is helping a minority of people who believe what he believes.
I'm so not prepared for you saying any of
this is really surprising to me.
Thank you to Katherine Wells so sincere thanks to her for reporting these two
segments and telling the story. Our
legal editor more perfect is produced by me Jad Abumrad with token low.
Kelsey Padgett and Suzy Lichtenberg who will take it from here
with Soren Wheeler.
Ellie missed all David Herman Alex Overington Karen Duff and Shawn Ramos were
Katherine Wells Barry Fingal Annie Mills Dylan Keith and Michelle Harris.
Special thanks to Dale Carpenter his book Flagrant Conduct is all about Lawrence
versus Texas. Thanks also to Lambda Legal Lisa Hardaway J.D.
Doyle Ari Berman Amy Howe and Charles.
Supreme Court audio is from OJ a free law project in collaboration with the
Legal Information Institute at Cornell.
Or perfect is funded in part by the William and Flora Hewlett Foundation the
Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation and the Joyce Foundation.